moi je les dis ici quand on a débattu
avec jacqueline moreau qui est une des
figures de la contestation je suis
d'accord avec la contestation
c'est à dire que je dénonce comme elle
l'entourloupe écologique qui consiste à
dire on va sauver la planète avec les
taxes alors qu'il s'agit simplement de
remplir les caisses de l'état et de
faire ses fins de mois
mais depuis lors j'ai observé que la
revendication n'a pas cessé de s'élargir
il y en a qui devant leur établissement
l'usf y en a qui demande la démission du
gouvernement
il y en a qui disent pourquoi pas si ça
pouvait entraîner macron dans un état de
droit c'est pas à la rue de renverser le
gouvernement ou d'exiger la démission
d'un président de la république ça c'est
la première chose qui m'embête parce que
la revendication devient extrêmement
vague est extrêmement peu démocratique
ensuite ce qui arrive et qui me semble
au moins aussi préoccupant c'est que
tous les partis extrémistes notamment
représenté ici par said he said pour
pour moi en tout cas essaye de se mettre
à la remorque de ce mouvement pour en
tirer partie justement donc je trouve
que ce qui était tout à fait honorable
qui était recevable à l'origine s'est
dilué de telle manière que le message
est brouillé et si c'est une révolte
je la soutiens si c'est une révolution
qui consiste à mettre cul par dessus
tête les institutions et bloquer le pays
je ne la soutient pas c'est pas comme ça
qu'on milite ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait bouger les choses il ya plein de
gens voilà qui récupère tout cela tous
ceux qui sont pas bien sûr voilà qui
sont pas en place le parti socialiste
soutient la mobilisation ils disent que
la colère des français est due à
l'augmentation des prix du carburant et
à une politique fiscale injuste la
france insoumise bien sûr derrière
jean-luc mélenchon soutien et souhaite
le succès de la mobilisation car il
estime qu'elle a du sens jean luc
mélenchon a dit a tweeté je souhaite le
succès du 17 novembre cette colère est
juste elle porte sur quelque chose qui a
un sens cette affaire d'augmentation des
carburants détrousse les braves gens qui
vivent de leur travail
on a bien sûr les républicains qui
participeront à la mobilisation avec
laurent wauquiez le président du parti
qui a d'ailleurs annoncé qu'il
participera au moment du 17 novembre
je le fais parce que je suis contre ces
hausses de taxes et que le gouvernement
n'écoute pas les français
il y a bien sûr florian philippot qui
est avec nous voilà qui est qui et qui
exactement qui est aussi pour il ya deux
bouts la france 2 sur nicolas dupont
aignan qui a d'ailleurs affiché son
soutien sur les réseaux les écologistes
ils disent comprendre la colère des
français
mais sans aller jusqu'à soutenir
mouvement alors on voit rassemblement
est ce que est ce que tous ces partis
politiques
est ce que c'est vraiment s qui est ce
qu'ils se disent oui les français
souffre ou et on a envie de faire
quelque chose peau ou bien ce qu'ils
disent c'est le moment de taper sur le
gouvernement en profite et les parties
et sont dans la rue l'arctique vous avez
cités oui au moins pour le parti
socialiste et des républicains ont
participé aux six chefs au matraquage
fiscal de ces dernières années ils
veulent faire une politique exactement
opposée à celle qu'ils ont données
exactes grâce à un peu bizarre c'est la
première chose et puis quand même on
entend beaucoup de démagogie parce que
faire croire aux gens que demain ça va
être un coup de baguette magique
voilà demain soir plutôt à changer je
verrai si je suis dit contrairement à
karim je ne pense pas que celui qui a
raison c'est celui d'un crie le plus
fort et on parlera donc je voudrais leur
âge de nos journaleux le dire calmement
qui ce n'est pas vrai et qui dit c'est
le seul moyen d'action il ya quand même
un problème en france où un français sur
deux ne va pas voter
il ya un taux de syndicalistes un des
plus faibles au monde je regrette ça ne
peut pas être le seul mouvement d'action
si ce qu'on fait croire aux gens
continuer de ne pas aller voter
continuer à ne pas vous syndiqués mes
deux mains sortait en masse et vous
verrez que tout va changer et réglo
mairie que c'est de la tromperie
démagogie et rideaux et chauffeurs
routiers donc initiateurs du mouvement
voulait réagir là-dessus je veux savoir
pourquoi tant de gens vont pas voter
justement parce qu' à aucun parti c'est
qu'il est ce qu'il ya un blog gens qui
n'y croient plus éric ses fûts divers
d'agents qui verrouille et s'ils ont
voté à gauche
il était de syriens la même merde ils
ont voté à droite ils sont toujours la
même merde ils ont vociféré lieu il
disait pas encore voilà sur un peu tancé
mal aurait pour l'instant il ya quand
même un argument il faut quand même dire
la vérité aussi
moi j'entends des tas de choses entendre
karim qui bon très bien qui mais il faut
quand même dire une chose qui est très
bien qu'ils aient quoi pas très bien qui
est qui qui donnent de la voix du muscle
très bien sucré séparation bouderradji
non pas du tout qui a ainsi juste un
passionné
il fallait 39 ans il faut dire il faut
dire attendez il est pas souvenir
l'aviron on vous aime comme ça me dire
la vérité link il faut dire la vérité
le pouvoir d'achat des français est dans
une situation absolument apocalyptique
et personne ne conteste si encore une
fois on voit pourquoi cette mobilisation
va sans doute mobiliser des millions de
gens demain mais il faut dire la vérité
c'est que aujourd'hui aucun parti
politique au gouvernement n'est capable
de dire comment la france assure ses
fins de mois vous savez sans doute que
depuis le 16 novembre de pardon de vue
avant-hier la france vit à crédit
la france vit à crédit s'avère que c'est
une chose de dire on va distribuer on va
investir
yakafocon c'est super facile oui très
bien mais je pense karim qui a pu un
français ou une française qui croient et
la réalité
sans vouloir être ultra négatif c'est
qu'à côté la question du pouvoir d'achat
des français
il ya un matraquage fiscal mais pourquoi
oui parce que l'état français est dans
une situation si elle reste trophique
catastrophe c'est à albi les coups qu'on
n'a pas entendu sur ce sujet bloqué tout
impôt et de pays est ce la solution pour
vous agace mais encore une fois l'at on
l'a tous répété ici on comprends cette
colère est en moi je vous comprends
complètement quand vous dites que vous
avez l'impression que c'est la seule
solution pour vous faire entendre
on l'entend tous et on comprend que la
seule question qu'on se pose c'est que
manifester c'est un droit résolument des
craintes démocratique il faut qu'on
défende et qu'on défend tous mais c'est
un droit encadré réguler pour éviter
justement un maximum de débordements si
encadrée par la police s'est essayée sur
9 stations et mais bien sûr que si c'est
ça descende dans la rue c'est le décès
le sait le déclarer à la préfecture à la
mairie à ce que vous voulez et faire en
sorte que le droit l'ordre public et la
sécurité de tout le pays soit respectée
on touche là ce qui nous pose le seul
petit problème là dessus c'est que vous
avez fait le choix de ne pas déclarer de
le garder c'est un petit peu se crée un
petit peu mystérieux même pas sûr qu'on
est obligé de suivre des consignes que
nous on n'a pas choisi donc du coup on a
décidé de pas du tout mais c'est les
pousser les consignes de la démographie
ressasse au plus court on peut sortir ça
où on veut on peut pas suivre le chemin
qu'on veut ma mère c'est que un moment
un rond-point un maître une femme qui a
envie de se rendre à son jeu
c'est pas des opérations de blocage les
options de filtrage ça et de d'escargots
on est resté sur le terme blocage mais
au fait c'est pas ça c'est que nous
consacrons c'est les soldes perry leslie
presse quel prix donc vous n'avez pas
faire des opérations de blocage mais le
but c'est de bloquer pays pour faire
avancer les choses
tous les gens voyaient pas donné toutes
les réunions qui ont été faites les
réunions d'information avec la police
jouer sur l'un des comptes qu'on voulait
c'est une voix sont choqués quand même
il est blessé en accord avec la police
justement on les a eus au téléphone se
souvenir cinq ans a alors laissé passer
les urgences les pompiers justement va
parler des policiers dans un instant
juste sur la récupération politique
énergétique satam aussi larry que je
vais avoir l'avis de florian la tum
s'ensuit la récupération politique pour
la première fois on aura les politiques
et les syndicats à leur vraie place
c'est à dire à la place à la place
qu'ils ont après pour reprendre
justement la volonté du peuple
écoutez le peuple est ensuite écouté
mettre en pratique ce que veut le peuple
là ils seront demain à leur place alors
ça je vais garder un écoutez le peuple
qui conduira tuyaux mais rigolo mais ils
prennent des décisions avant d'écouter
le peuple écouter le peuple ils ont la
main et maintenant ensuite prenez des
décisions et il faut qu'il soit en
deuxième place après le peuple alors je
regarde philippot franchement y'a pas un
petit peu de récupération mais est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas engouffré dans la
brèche voilà je pense qu'on a un coup à
jouer
mais non excusez là le voir elle seule
chose qu'on souhaite récupérer c'est le
pouvoir d'achat des français
moins glamour ce que vous venez de dire
est parfaitement exact pour lui
parfaitement il avait rien vous l'avez
écouté compris notre rôle n'est pas
d'organiser nous les manifestations
mouvement politique ce n'est pas notre
rôle
mais dire aussi que le politique de
vraies compétences d engager ce serait
extrêmement démagogique sinon et ça
tourne en rond il y aura jamais de
solution il faut proposer un débouché
politique
moi je suis très je suis très serein sur
ce mouvement ça fait des années et des
années je dis qu'il faut baisser les
taxes sur le carburant j'ai pas changé
d'avis qu'il faut taxer les grandes
compagnies pétrolières qu'il faut mettre
en place des transports en commun
beaucoup moins cher et plus performant
bref donc là dessus moi je suis très
cohérent mais vous disiez tout à l'heure
oui mais et le sait ils ont voté à
gauche sans doute à droite son côté
macro un peu des deux mélangés donc et
ça donne toujours la même chose oui oui
ça donne soit une chose donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut changer 1
moment et on changera pas si on reste
dans ce cadre cupide libéral et européen
ces saintes un débouché politique voyez
sinon on va tourner en rond on y aura
toujours le problème ça qui va se finir
philippe exactement de faire voilà ce
qu'on dénonce vous dites les autres ils
ont fait de la merde mais nous c'est moi
faire mieux en moi je veux bien faire
mais on fait tous les jours la même si
ça marche pas m et du coup on est on est
extrêmement triste parce que vous
reprenez des mamelles mémoire vous avez
aucune honte vous y aller à fond vous
repreniez triste vous reprenez les
colères de monsieur drouet et de tous
les autres noms mais j'ai les jeunes et
tous les autres qui sont à l'intérieur
pour vous positionner soit de futures
élections européennes les nouvelles de
la récupérer des manhwas ce que ces gars
les battous heure de jeu laissant les
vêtements leurs manifestations les
citoyens aussi je dis simplement moi je
dis ce que je veux dire ce soir je le
disais déjà il ya un an
donc j'ai pas déplaire au 15 mai dès 13
ans - mais avec l'argent on le prend
doucement
vous n'êtes pas obligé d pourquoi le
feraient si les transports vous avez
fait sur le rail
c'est vrai que c'était une demande de
l'union européenne attendait à toi à moi
mais je vois le gouvernement nous jouer
l'air de la sécurité etc
tout nous est sensible à ces questions
il annonce aussi premier lieu mais
beaucoup plus que par exemple le 1er mai
quand y avait 2000 black blocks qui
voulaient aller tabasser tout le monde
là on les entendait pas parce que ça les
arrange et parce que c'est un mouvement
social contre la libéralisation du rail
et le gouvernement voulait discréditer
ce mouvement social donc un deux poids
deux mesures la salisienne c'est vrai
que c'est les français c'est les gueux
c'est les gens c'est les petites gens tu
sais les bonnes jambes
d'où les questions de comme ça pas de
ces gens là ce mouvement c'est la france
d oublier celle qui ferme sa gueule en
permanence qui va aller dans la lnh se
fait sucer teinte appelée par monsieur
sur indices vous dites bon total
là c'est vous qui est démagogique ils
sont très loin de la faillite moi je
veux juste les surtaxer fait son
business
non me font humilier ses passes à ses
trois jours et six pieds c'est au succès
du récent des deuxièmement vous me dites
tous les ya pas que ma tronche bien
d'accord avec vous déjà sous sarkozy
soit hollande ça moi c'est pour ça que
je pointe du doigt sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui s'effondre et services
publics qui disparaissent qui est un
enjeu de mobilisation de moins de demain
je pointe du doigt une cause dont
personne ne parle jamais c'est là
l'union européenne du personnel et al
c'est sûr c'est pas dû regarder sous
d'austérité ne sait rien et c'est wade
paris tenait juste mosquée c'est parce
qu'on est dans ce qui me dérange donc
moi j'apporte j'essaie d'apprendre qu'un
élu chef politique après on en débat ce
qui me dérange monsieur philippe hausse
et que vous êtes un responsable
politique
vous dites demain sortez dans la rue ou
dis pas que c'est archi série l'a dit de
façon anarchique
imaginons que les gens là qui sortent
dans la rue en face et fanny z et aux
fonds non c'est non pas de gagner
c'était débordements vous allez dire
quoi derrière bien ce pas baisser tant
qu'ils avaient incité des gens est
derrière la petite robe d'été des majors
sur tout le monde à le faire aucun
débordement à aucun débordement
ce que je remarque c'est que les manifs
et n'a peur qu'elle est organisée où il
ya eu beaucoup débordements comme le 1er
mai le gouvernement était beaucoup moins
soucieux que vous êtes un représentant
de politique
votre rôle c'est de faire de la
pédagogie vous parlez de cette france
des oubliés vous parler de cette france
pourvu pourquoi ne pas parler de ces
gens qui vont demain alors quand on est
mère de famille femmes seules demain on
doit aller bosser on peut pas aller
bosser on perd 80 euros à peu près d'un
journée quand on sait que mais plus de
50 % des français sont déjà découvert le
3 ou le 4 du mois ce que vous êtes en
train d'encourager n'est pas
encourageants qu'attendu en dessous
d'eux
a peut-être trop nommé à 72 70 %
effectivement qui soutiennent le
mouvement
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut pas
leur propre mère de radiation direction
du débat c'est est ce que c'est la
solution la solution est d'aller bloquer
on se tait d'aller bloquer budget
ce kit doivent être gêné pas les
français
la mère de vanessa selbst le samedi
comme alpha elle est bloquée qui macron
il est vous pouvez pas l'approcher alors
il ya deux choses d'abord j'ai l'affreux
sur son monsieur philippot que vous
encourager cette manifestation parce
qu'il y aura plus de manifestations de
manifestants que vous aurez jamais de
d'électeurs donc barack obama sont
heureusement dans ses meetings ont
sifflé trompe il a dit ne sifflait pas
aller voter
moi je dis aux gens pas la peine d'aller
dans ces manifestations votez ne restez
pas chez ça va mais vous devez démocrate
argument c'est que j'allais monoski
vivre dans le confort
et qui dit mais aller voter attendez
j'ai un jour mais là il a réussi à faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le droit de manifester notre pays
connaît peur pour la sécurité qu'on le
dise je regarde les manifestants demain
les atteintes à lucio soyez prudent
sinon tout le monde va vous tirer dessus
et marcher tranquille omar soyez zen
soyez joyeux ça ne le fait pas mais ils
n'y vont pas pour casser ce sont des
travailleurs et des jeunes qui
travaillent qui nous est arrivé à
manifester on est d'accord mais alors
que chez un peu mal à misano mais ne dit
pas c'est pas possible c'est pas la
solution
d'accord qu'ils ont le droit de
manifester
ce qu'on ne veut pas c'est qu'ils à
merde excusez moi tous les autres non
c'est aussi cela j'ai mon frère et ma
soeur qui sauront ils manifestants ils
ont raison de manifester pacifiquement
ç'a toujours été des emmerdeurs à son
nom mais les pauvres
si les gens qui vont aller dans la rue
de marly j'entends d'ici peu ils sont
obligés de faire ça il n'aurait on peut
pas dire hydro merde et les autres mais
non ils le font c'est pour les ou l'exil
au vert pour les autres c'est bien
qu'ils le fassent mais c'est encore plus
à leur avantage
s'il ne se passe rien parce que là parce
qu'on allait vous réalisez les cidres et
b s'est pas décidé si ça bouge
et si ça fait bouger les choses ceux qui
seront restés chez eux seront bien
contents a mentionné que vous ressentez
dans la maison on va revenir là dessus a
les chiffres mais allez-y
on me dit à 80% des français qui
soutiennent et ça me croyez pas 80% de
face et qui vont donc ils vont dans la
rue allant de mai à août en données
[Musique]
consolidées
ça c'est pour ça qu'ils bossent bien
hamdaoui
c'est un joueur de l'équipe de france de
rugby faux grossier doigt samedi donc
arrêté